[Music]
if you love what you do you want to do
it as much as you can for as long as you
can you know I mean it's just that
simple to me it's not really work it's
just this is what I drove told me was
someone I was just always wanted to kind
of be like and play like she's being a
competitor revolutionized the shooting
guard position and it's brought so much
beauty to the game like Kobe I look up
to Kobe Bryant
[Applause]
not so much for a game you know I pretty
much put the ball and a lot of people's
hands trying to make them be like Kobe
where's they come to my mind when I hear
black Mambo
we're the deadliest strikers it's always
trying to take your heart out and you
got to be ready for that we think I
learned came from cold
[Applause]
everybody wait times and hours
don't ever question the heart of that
guy I just want to go out and play for
handle that Mamba mentality I'm not
afraid to fail everybody in the crowd
stands up and everybody's weak and see
if you gonna make the shot younger guys
look up to
we looked up to him I look up to what
his impact will forever being part of
this game he's a legend legend ever died
so try to remember you don't have that
much time to play this game you know
you're able to remember you know for the
great things that you did and positive
things that you did making people feel
great that's a pretty cool thing
[Music]
[Music]
you